23 de junio de 2016
Una fecha que pasará a la historia. Ese
día, el 51,9% de los británicos votaron
por abandonar la Unión Europea. El divorcio se
había consumado. El Brexit se haría realidad.
Que por supuesto es, exactamente, lo
que pasó. Pero, ¿os acordáis de cuáles
fueron las principales promesas de la
campaña ProBrexit? Pues… Hubo muchos,
pero esta fue con mucha diferencia una
de las más importantes y decisivas.
(El Brexit es la única forma de controlar la
inmigración, afirman los activistas. The Guardian)
De hecho, tal y como podéis ver, las encuestas
anteriores al referéndum mostraban claramente
que la inmensa mayoría de los británicos,
fueran o no partidarios del Brexit,
consideraban que este le permitiría al
gobierno británico volver a controlar las
fronteras y reducir así la enorme cantidad de
inmigrantes que estaban entrando en el país.
El Brexit suponía muchas cosas, pero,
electoralmente hablando, pasaba sobre todo
por controlar la inmigración y los efectos
que esta provocaba en el sistema de salud,
en los colegios, en el mercado de trabajo
y en la vida diaria de los británicos.
Pues bien, desde entonces, han pasado
ni más ni menos que 7 largos años. Y
la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es, ¿qué ha supuesto exactamente
el Brexit para la inmigración? ¿Ha
cumplido realmente esta promesa?
Pues… Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik los
datos parecen decir algo muy diferente.
N2(24 de noviembre de 2022: La inmigración
del Reino Unido casi se triplica a pesar
de las promesas del Brexit. DW)
(8 de julio de 2023: Los cruces de
inmigrantes por el Canal de la Mancha alcanzan
un nuevo récord diario en 2023. The Telegraph)
El debate sobre la inmigración se ha convertido en
uno de los temas centrales
en el 10 de Downig Street.
Pese a que ahora el Reino Unido
puede manejar de nuevo sus fronteras,
la llegada de inmigrantes no solo no se ha
reducido, sino que se ha incrementado. Y eso
a pesar de que la situación económica
del país no es particularmente buena.
Y la pregunta que podemos hacernos es, ¿hasta qué
punto el Reino Unido se ha convertido en un país
abierto a la inmigración? ¿Qué ha pasado con la
que fue una de las grandes promesas del Brexit?
¿Sabías que el equipo de Sunak espera hacer
de la inmigración, o mejor dicho, de la lucha
contra la inmigración su gran apuesta política
de cara a las próximas elecciones del año 2025?
Pues bien… En este vídeo vamos a
conocer todos los detalles sobre
la enorme ola de inmigración que
está experimentando el Reino Unido.
Arranquemos.
[Por cierto, hablando de Reino
Unido. ¿Sabías que su economía
no está atravesando sus mejores momentos?
Por ejemplo, las estimaciones nos dicen que
los salarios reales del Reino Unido
son hoy más bajos que hace 15 años,
al tiempo que la inflación ha batido su peor
registro en las últimas 4 décadas, El Brexit, la
falta de inversión y muchos problemas regulatorios
han creado una situación de extrema debilidad.
Desde el año 2007 la producción por hora de
esta economía apenas ha crecido un 0,7% anual,
el segundo peor registro del G7, tan solo
por detrás de Italia. La pregunta es, ¿Qué
le está pasando a la economía británica? ¿Cómo
puede el Reino Unido escapar de esta situación?
No os perdáis el vídeo que Si lo Hubiera
Sabido, el canal de información financiera de
Mutuactivos ha publicado sobre este tema. Es muy
esclarecedor. Os dejo el link en la descripción.
Dicho esto, continuemos.]
T1 (¡ABRAN LAS PUERTAS!)
Queridos amigos, es imposible hablar
del Reino Unido post-Brexit sin
mencionar a Alexander Boris de Pfeffel
Johnson. Ya sabéis, a Boris Johnson.
Sí, el mismo tipo que era capaz de ofrecer
té a los periodistas por la mañana;
Pegarse con un paraguas al mediodía;
Y aplacar a niños durante
partidos de rugby por las tardes.
En resumidas cuentas,
uno de los personajes más pintorescos y
controvertidos de la política moderna.
Un político que fue uno de los grandes
defensores y promotores del Brexit.
De hecho, fue probablemente el líder conservador
más importante en defender esta postura. Y sí,
entre las razones, Johnson también hablaba de la
inmigración y el control de las fronteras. Fijaos,
Y aún más, Johnson insistía una y otra
vez en que seguir formando parte de la
Unión Europea suponía renunciar a tener
cualquier control sobre la frontera.
C1 (“Es profundamente corrosivo para la
confianza popular en la democracia que
cada año los políticos del Reino Unido
le digan al público que pueden reducir
la inmigración a decenas de miles, y luego
descubren que no logran sus objetivos por
cientos de miles” Boris Johnson, mayo 2016)
Ojo, esto no quiere decir que Johnson fuese un
líder antiinmigración ni nada por el estilo.
Simplemente, decía no estar de acuerdo con
la llegada descontrolada de cientos y
cientos de miles de personas cada año.
Pero al mismo tiempo también
decía cosas como estas:
N4 (Boris Johnson dice que
la baja inmigración podría
conducir al estancamiento económico. The Guardian)
Sea como sea, en aquel momento Johnson era
el alcalde de Londres y aunque ya se veía
que su objetivo era claramente llegar al
10 de Downing Street, tuvo que esperar.
Tras la dimisión de David Cameron, que había
hecho campaña por mantenerse en la Unión Europea,
se hizo con el timón de mando su
ministra de Exteriores, Teresa May.
(May fracasó estrepitosamente a la hora de
gestionar las negociaciones para completar el
Brexit. Su dimisión le dio el liderazgo del
gobierno a Boris Johnson en julio de 2019.
Entonces, una de las primeras cosas
que hizo el nuevo primer ministro
británico fue comenzar a trabajar
precisamente en el tema migratorio.
De esta forma, en marzo de 2021 su gobierno
presentó un nuevo plan para la política de
inmigración. Un plan que finalmente devino
en un proyecto de ley presentado a la Cámara
de los Comunes a finales de junio de ese
mismo 2021, y aprobada en abril de 2022.)
[Sí, desde hace ya casi una década la política
británica vive practicamente
obsesionada con este tema.]
Ahora bien, si tenemos en cuenta la llegada
de extranjeros, durante la etapa Johnson
las cosas no cambiaron demasiado, excepto
porque la inmigración se disparó aún más.
Por ejemplo, podemos echar un vistazo
a lo ocurrido con los refugiados.
Tal y como podéis ver, en 2019 las autoridades
británica aprobaron un 70% más de solicitudes. Y
tras la pandemia los números crecieron aún más.
Y esto es tan solo un ejemplo. Porque lo cierto
es que las visas de trabajo también se
dispararon desde que Johnson llegó al
gobierno. En 2022 se otorgaron casí un 70% más
que en 2016, el año del referendum. Fijaos.
Y la pregunta qué podemos hacernos es, ¿Qué
demonios pasó? ¿No se supone que el Brexit
defendía limitar la inmigración? ¿No era acaso
Johnson un firme partidario de controlar las
fronteras? ¿Es que acaso el Reino Unido se
ha convertido un modelo de puertas abiertas?
Pues bien, hechas las preguntas,
vayamos con las respuestas.
T2 (CAMBIO DE JUEGO)
El Reino Unido, tal y como
ocurre con el resto de Europa,
tiene una enorme necesidad de mano de obra joven.
Lo tiene porque su población cada vez está
más envejecida, pero también porque las
empresas necesitan perfiles muy diferentes.
Desde aquellos orientados a trabajos poco
cualificados y de muy poco valor añadido
que los británicos ya no quieren hacer,
hasta aquellos perfiles muy especializados que son
imprescindibles para las industrias más punteras.
Por ejemplo, para la industria tecnológica o para
la importantísima industria financiera británica.
Así que Johnson llegó al 10 de Downing
Street con esta contradicción entre manos:
Por un lado, se suponía que tenía que cumplir
con las promesas del Brexit y sacar adelante
una reforma que ordenara y redujera la
llegada de extranjeros. Pero, por otro,
tenía que ser una reforma que no supusiera
un obstáculo para la economía nacional.
Y la pregunta es, ¿qué pensáis
que ocurrió? Pues ya lo hemos
visto. Los datos no nos generan ninguna duda.
¿Y sabéis qué es lo más curioso? Que todo esto no
erosiono particularmente
la popularidad de Johnson.
De repente, lo que era un tema tan
absolutamente importante, incluso
para determinar la salida de la Unión Europea,
se convirtió en… Ba… Algo menos trascendente.
De hecho, según un estudio elaborado por el
Instituto de Política del King's College de
Londres, desde el Brexit el rechazo de los
británicos hacia los trabajadores extranjeros
se ha derrumbado. Una tendencia diferente a lo que
está ocurriendo en países como Australia o Canadá.
Los británicos parecen estar volviéndose mucho
más abiertos y receptivos inmediatamente después
de abandonar la Unión Europea, pese a que el
principal motivo electoral de los pro-Brexit
fue precisamente echar el cierre y reducir
drásticamente la llegada de extranjeros.
Qué es exactamente lo contrario a
lo que está sucediendo. Y aún más,
ni eso erosionó particularmente al gobierno
ni tampoco los británicos parecen molestos.
Y ojo, porque el rechazo a los inmigrantes
se ha desplomado entre todos los grupos de
edad. No importa si hablamos de la
generación Z, de los millennials,
de los baby boomers o de la generación
Pre-Guerra. De hecho, en este último caso,
el rechazo se ha desplomado a menos de la
mitad en los últimos años, hasta apenas el 8%.
Y la pregunta, lógicamente, es, ¿por
qué? Pues probablemente por esto:
(La economía británica no está atravesando
su mejor momento, pero, aun así, la tasa de
desempleo es muy baja y hay muchas profesiones
con una enorme carencia de profesionales.
Eso explica, por ejemplo, por qué
según una reciente encuesta de
Ipsos los británicos están como locos
por qué lleguen al país más médicos,
más profesionales de enfermería
e, incluso, más agricultores.
De hecho, menos del 20% de los británicos
quieren ahora que se reduzca la llegada
de profesionales de prácticamente
cualquier actividad. Curiosamente,
la única excepción son los banqueros.)
[Pero está claro que esa fobia tiene mucho más que
ver con los bancos que los
trabajadores de los bancos.]
Y eso no es todo. Este mismo estudio de Ipsos
muestra que el 46% de los británicos valora
positivamente el impacto de la inmigración,
frente a lo un 29% que lo valora negativamente.
Una percepción negativa que, curiosamente,
no ha dejado de reducirse desde,
precisamente, el año 2016.
Es decir, que ahora que
llegan muchos más inmigrantes,
los británicos ya no están preocupadas.
Claro que una cosa son los británicos y otra
los políticos. El actual gobierno conservador
está sacando adelante una reforma de la ley
migratoria tan polémica que incluso está detrás
el Tribunal Europeo de Derechos Humanos. ¿Queréis
saber de qué estoy hablando? Pues… Veámoslo.
T3 (¿JUGANDO CON FUEGO?)
Amigos, puede que a los británicos ya no les
importa mucho el tema de la inmigración, pero,
en cambio, los políticos siguen erre que erre.
En abril de 2022, el gobierno de Johnson logró
que se aprobara su nuevo plan de inmigración.
Por ejemplo, la nueva ley introdujo un sistema
de dos niveles que ofrecía a los refugiados
diferentes niveles de protección dependiendo
de cómo ingresaran al Reino Unido. A los que
ingresaban por “rutas seguras y legales” se les
concede permiso para quedarse sin condiciones;
pero aquellos que ingresen de forma irregular,
solo podían aspirar a una
estancia temporal de 30 meses.
Y no solo eso. La reforma también perseguía
darle a la Marina británica el control de las
aguas territoriales del Canal y encargarse
de controlar la inmigración por esa vía. Y,
además, se incluyó esta otra posibilidad:
C2 (“Si van por ese camino, si cruzan el
Canal de la Mancha ilegalmente en esos botes,
se arriesgan a terminar no en el Reino
Unido, sino en Ruanda”. Boris Johnson.)
Sí, lo habéis oído bien. Para
combatir la inmigración ilegal,
el gobierno de Johnson alcanzó un acuerdo
con Ruanda para que este país recibiera
a todos aquellos inmigrantes que no
fueran aceptados por el Reino Unido.
Básicamente, las autoridades
británicas derivarían al país
africano a todas aquellas personas con
solicitudes rechazadas, que no fueran
consideradas aptas o que estuvieran
viviendo en el país de forma ilegal.
Pues bien, el primer vuelo bajo este nuevo plan
de deportaciones masivas estaba programado para
el día 14 de junio de 2022, pero tuvo que
ser suspendido por una medida cautelar del
Tribunal Europeo de Derechos Humanos, ya
que la idea británica parecía chocar con
múltiples convenciones internacionales. Además,
existen serías dudas de que sea la mejor opción.
N5 (El historial de Ruanda en la acogida de
deportados suscita inquietud ante el esquema
del Reino Unido. De unas 4.000 personas que se
estima fueron deportadas por Israel a Ruanda y
Uganda bajo un esquema de “salida voluntaria”
entre 2014 y 2017, se cree que casi todas
abandonaron el país casi de inmediato, y muchas
intentaron regresar a Europa. The Guardian)
Por su parte, la experiencia de Australia, que
durante años ha hecho con los inmigrantes ilegales
algo muy parecido, también ha despertado
muchas críticas y muchas, muchísimas dudas.
N6 (Los refugiados de Nauru, la isla
donde los niños perdieron el deseo
de vivir. "Hemos comenzado a ver conductas
suicidas en niños de tan sólo ocho y 10 años",
dice Louise Newman, profesora de psiquiatría
de la Universidad de Melbourne, Australia,
que trabaja con familias y niños en la isla. BBC)
El caso es que las crisis de gobierno de Boris
Johnson primero y de Liz Truss después, pararon
la alternativa de Ruanda… Pese a ello, y pese
a todas las críticas, podemos decir que Johnson
tenía una posición razonablemente aperturista… Al
menos si la comparamos con la situación actual.
Porque ahora, ahora hay un nuevo gobierno.
¿Y sabéis qué? El equipo de Rishi Sunak se
ha sumergido en una enorme batalla parlamentaria
para sacar adelante su propia reforma de la misma
ley que ya fue modificada hace poco más de un
año a instancias del gobierno de Boris Johnson.
¡Y eso que son del mismo partido!
Lo más curioso es que pese a que el rechazo
de los británicos a la llegada de inmigrantes
y refugiados se ha desplomado… El gobierno
de Sunak quiere endurecer la ley de Johnson.
Si, por ejemplo, esa ley permitía que los
refugiados que ingresaran irregularmente
en el país pudieran optar a un permiso
de permanencia de 30 meses, ahora el
objetivo del gobierno británico es impedir que
cualquier persona que entre de forma irregular
pueda conseguir ningún permiso ni estatus
de residencia, ni siquiera el de refugiado.
La idea del Sunak es que si entras irregularmente
en el país ni tu ni tampoco tus hijos podréis
lograr ningún tipo de permiso de residencia.
El espíritu es que si entras irregularmente,
sea cual sea tu situación, te enfrentarás
sí o sí a la detención y la deportación.
C3 (“El proyecto de ley modificará
radicalmente la forma de tratar a
las personas que llegan ilegalmente al
Reino Unido a través de países seguros,
haciendo inadmisibles sus solicitudes
de asilo y de protección de los derechos
humanos (respecto a su país de origen)
e imponiendo al ministro del Interior la
obligación de expulsarlas..” Robert Jenrick -
Secretario de Estado (ministro) de Inmigración)
Y, ojo, que esto supone cargarse de
facto la figura del asilo político.
Reino Unido ya no sería un destino posible
para aquellas personas que se ven obligadas
a marcharse lo antes posible de sus
países por estar siendo perseguidos.
Vale que hay mucho fraude, pero evidentemente,
en muchas situaciones, si tu vida o tu libertad
corren un peligro inminente, por ejemplo, por
ideas políticas o por defender la democracia,
no te vas a poner a realizar trámites
burocráticos que te puede llevar años.
Pues bien, el plan de Sunak
no tendría nada de eso en
cuenta. Esta es una de las pri80
ncipales críticas a una apuesta
política que como veis es muy estricta,
mucho más que la apuesta de Johnson.
Pero, eso no es todo. Justo aquí es donde
la cosa se pone particularmente cruda.
Ahora el gobierno de Sunak ha redoblado su apuesta
y ya ha oficializado el acuerdo con Ruanda,
pese a que, según las encuestas, la mayoría
de los británicos están en contra del mismo.
C4 (“El objetivo de este Acuerdo es crear
un mecanismo para la reubicación de los
solicitantes de asilo cuyas solicitudes no
estén siendo estudiadas por el Reino Unido,
en Ruanda, que tramitará sus solicitudes
y asentará o expulsará (según proceda)
a las personas una vez que se decida sobre su
solicitud.” Memorándum de entendimiento entre el
gobierno de Ruanda y el gobierno de Reino Unido)
Y la pregunta, la gran pregunta es…
Si aparentemente los británicos ya
no tienen tantos problemas con la
inmigración y si están en contra
de deportar a la gente a Ruanda,
¿por qué este empeño político?
Pues básicamente por esto:
N7 (6 de mayo. Elecciones locales 2023: Los
laboristas superan a los conservadores como
partido mayoritario en el gobierno local. Sky)
La pandemia, la caída de Johnson,
la crisis de Liz Truss, la inflación,
la subida de tipos, el estado de la
economía… El partido conservador se está
enfrentando a una dura crisis electoral.
Tal y como podéis ver en este
gráfico, las encuestas son claras:
de cara a las próximas elecciones de 2025, hoy por
hoy los laboristas parecen los claros favoritos.
Y la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo es,
¿qué pinta en todo esto la inmigración? Pues
básicamente que todo apunta a que el gobierno
de Sunak quiere volver a convertirla en
uno de sus grandes caballos de batalla.
Es decir, que el gobierno podría querer volver
a poner esta cuestión en el candelero para
demostrar mano dura y fuerza. Es algo que a los
conservadores les funcionó en el pasado y por
eso ahora parece que quieren volver a intentarlo.
Y precisamente por eso están lanzando mensajes e
iniciativas particularmente duras como recluir
a los inmigrantes ilegales en un enorme barco.
N8 (7 de agosto de 2023: Gran Bretaña
comienza a recluir a inmigrantes en
una embarcación calificada de
"trampa mortal" por los bomberos
Que, ¿qué queréis, qué os diga? Convertir
todo esto en una especie de espectáculo y
anuncios publicitarios no parece la
mejor forma de tratar este problema.
Por supuesto, esto se está haciendo
esencialmente con los refugiados y
los inmigrantes ilegales. Porque a la hora de
la verdad, lo más probable es que Reino Unido
siga emitiendo tantos permisos de trabajo,
viene haciendo hasta ahora. Al fin y al cabo,
si algo está claro, es que la economía británica
va a seguir necesitando mucha mano de obra nueva.
En otras palabras, que más allá de lo importante
que resulta desincentivar la inmigración ilegal
o de si hay cosas que mejorar o no en el sistema
migratorio británico, hay muchas sospechas de que
los últimos cambios legales podrían responder
a un criterio fundamentalmente electoral. Con
todos los problemas que tiene Reino Unido
esto no parece una prioridad sensata.
Pero sea como sea, llegados
hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Qué te parece la apuesta política
de Sunak? ¿Estás de acuerdo con las
deportaciones a Ruanda? ¿Qué te
parecen ese tipo de iniciativas?
Déjanos como siempre tus
impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate. Ahora si este vídeo te
ha resultado interesante, no olvides darle
a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.